Recently at my job we got a new supervisor,
one who happens to be retired army.
After 20 years.
He and I had a pretty heavy running two which resulted in getting HR involved.
The end result was that I would not be written up for what he claimed I was
doing.
He tried to make an example out of me almost as soon as he got here.
Assuming I was easy,
he assumed I was an easy target anyways to the point even though he and I had a
falling out,
I'd still like to see the guy succeed at his job and become a great leader.
After listening to your podcast over the last month,
I'm making an effort to improve our relationship at this job instead of just
avoiding the men I've re.
I've recently purchased your book extreme ownership.
How would you suggest are present this book to my new supervisor and read or to
read without feeling as if I'm belittling him as to say he needs work on his
leadership.
I think he could benefit from it greatly.
Good question.
Yeah,
it's actually a question I've answered on here before.
Answer it again because I even learned when I repeat.
Sure.
This is my latest version of what I tell people when they're in the situation.
Yeah.
Updated version because you get better at things and you figure out better ways
to overcome challenges,
especially when you're presented with the same challenge over and over again,
which I kind of am.
Yeah man.
Some challenges like this one,
so here's what,
here's what you do.
You give it to him and you say,
you know,
hey boss or hey person,
hey,
I got this book and I'm trying to really emulate the principles that are in this
book.
It,
it really hit me and I,
I was wondering if I could ask you a favor,
if you could just look through this book,
kind of see what the principles are and then if you see me falling out,
align with the principles of that are in this book,
let me know so I can fix them.
Basic things like if I'm not taking ownership of problems,
if I'm,
if I'm not keeping things simple,
if I'm not supporting other people around me covering and moving for them,
just let me know.
That's all I'm asking because I'm,
I'm really trying to do a better job.
Could you do that for me?
So then the person says,
well,
yeah,
okay,
fine.
You know,
and then they read the book and when they read the book,
sure there's a chance that they'll be thinking like,
oh,
this book is about everyone else and it's not about me.
Right,
right.
That's possible.
There is also a chance,
a higher chance that they read the book and go,
Ooh,
I make a lot of excuses and I blame other people all the time.
I'm probably not doing a great job as a leader and that might be subconscious.
I see that sometimes now where people are subconsciously making adjustments
because they don't want to admit that they're the person that's,
that,
that the problem,
they don't want to admit that there are the problems.
So they make these little adjustments kind of subconsciously.
And other people will tell me that the boss is like changing.
Oh yeah,
they're,
they're changing their game.
They won't admit it,
but they are changing their game.
So that's what you hope for is that they do,
they go through that transfer,
that transformation from,
you know,
not taking ownership and treating people bad and not trying to build
relationships and all that stuff that makes them into a bad leader in to taking
ownership,
building relationships,
covering,
moving,
keeping things simple,
all the stuff that makes you a good leader.
That's what the hope is.
Now
there's also a chance that this person's gonna hold a grudge,
right?
We,
we,
we got to deal with that.
And I'll tell you,
I was recently talking to someone that had stepped on the toes of another
business,
another division inside their business,
another sales division.
And you know,
salespeople are sort of known for being protective and aggressive,
like protective of their territory.
Well this guy kind of stepped into their territory a little bit cause,
cause some bad,
bad vibes.
Giant rift.
And he's like,
you don't want,
what should I do?
You know why I feel like all this animosity now,
and it's one of those times where I just said to myself,
well,
what would I actually do if I was in that situation?
How would I try and get this problem solved?
Well,
what I would do is walk up to the person who I stepped into their territory and
cause problems and I'd say,
Hey,
hey,
I wanted to tell you I,
I,
I totally was out of line when I stepped into your territory,
that that was completely my fault.
And you know,
I was just got target fixation,
which is bad.
I didn't talk to you,
I stepped into your world,
which is bad and I left a disaster and I,
I'm sorry.
That's that.
All that stuff,
everything that I just said,
all my fault and I want to let you know that I completely recognize it.
And number one,
anything I can do to try and redeem that and make it up and make you realize
that,
and anything I can do to support and help you move forward,
I don't,
I will not let that happen again.
I just want to let you know that.
So boom,
just step up and be humble,
apologize and say,
Hey,
can you,
what can I do to help you?
What can I do to support you?
That's where I would go with these,
with this question.
And then a sort of a,
uh,
an addition to that question.
It's kind of like,
you know,
when you,
when you give your both the book,
right,
it'd be like,
Hey,
this is what I'm doing.
Is that kind of like when you,
when you get,
you know,
like if somebody has a bad,
bad breath and then you put in gum,
you know,
you eat some gum,
he,
hey,
you want some gum?
Yeah.
That's very similar.
You just break out the gum.
You know,
I was like to do this,
you know,
just to make sure I was like to have a piece of gum,
just to make sure you know a lot of fun.
Oh,
you want one?
You might want to take too.